in sieben leben freunde ich bin total
fertig irgendwie habe ich die video days
wirklich komplett zerstört ich habe
jetzt voll die halsschmerzen ich bin
genau da fährt um eine neue brutale
realität auch im gerade jetzt wo ich sah
mich mein kolloquium in der uni das
heißt weil sie eine mündliche prüfung
zum bachelor arbeit wir haben einen von
verschiedenen dozenten kann ich fragen
zur arbeit nicht präsentieren deswegen
schneide ich mir auch mein nicht orden
bad oder gesagt man soll sich
dementsprechend für den anlass anziehen
deswegen ja ich sehe aus wie ein pinguin
spielglück freunde ich glaube jetzt
dahin und dann geht's los
zwei stunden später ich wieder zu hause
angekommen ich hatte gerade die prüfung
ihr fragt euch wahrscheinlich was ich
bekommen habe also eine schriftliche
bachelor habe die die halt da über 70
seiten gegenwart perfekte arbeit waren
23 kombiniert mit einer mündlichen
leistungen allerdings die nach 1,3 was
dementsprechend 2,0 arbeiten praktikum
damals war der 17 das heißt da hingehen
kombiniert habe ich 185 schnitt und da
ich schriftlich 1,7 stehe habe ich jetzt
sich an bachelor mit 218 kann man machen
eben besser geht aber auf ihr
schlechtestes das einfach so irre so ich
habe jetzt einfach mein studium beendet
drei jahre einfach jetzt vorbei was ich
halt nur so ein bisschen komisch fand
war so die begründung warum die
bachelorarbeit einfach nur ne 2,3 war
einfach ein lokal dort nicht so viele
buch quellen
das ist fucking influenza marketing auf
youtube das gibt seit ein paar jahren
ich habe meinen bachelor jetzt finito
ich wollte dass er die logan ist
gegessen habe mache ich mir jetzt
erstmal bei weißbrot die putenbrust und
ein typisches luca frühstück zeige ich
jetzt mal was ich mit den eiern von
helfern machte war sind die eier von
hater und ich mache
[Applaus]
was bin ich für mensch alter messen geht
tatsächlich da wo man natürlich auch
sagen muss bei rührei und ein bisschen
kicken mit ihr trautes aus dem eiweiß
pro dokument hatte ich auch nicht so
viel falsch machen dass es mir schlecht
ich habe gerade meine sachen hier weil
ich jetzt für sechs tage nach hause da
bielefeld meiner familie fahre ich würde
sagen wir fragen ist mein vater von
meiner bachelorarbeit hält was die welt
besser gemacht hast du schluckauf
ich mache jetzt auf jeden fall ist noch
weiter meine sachen fluffy an der du
kannst leider nicht mitkommen also ich
muß ich habe zu hause wirklich also ich
mach ja davon fällt mit
das kommt kein zweites mal vorschuss
köln wunderschöne stadt es ist
unglaublich was gibt's da vorne zu
meckern auf den billigen plätzen
verdammte scheiße jetzt 80 mann fährt zu
den 35 war mir immer nach einer
wundervoll entspannt parat wenn ich
jetzt zu hause aber familie angekommen
eventuell könnte euch daran erinnern
dass ich auch von einem fan eine
aufblasbare pizza luftmatratze bekommen
habe und ich würde sagen wir gehen jetzt
einfach mal raus und pumpen die auf die
leute die mir bei snap chat oder bei
instagram folgen ist wahrscheinlich dass
meine eltern hier in bielefeld und
kleinen pool haben deswegen werde ich
hier immer die matratze austesten können
und köln geht das halt leider nicht so
gut da ich habe keinen pool tag diesmal
auf jeden fall an der stelle noch mal
danke an momente und lukas klobrille für
diese luftmatratze
ich hoffe ihr habt da keine scheiße mit
angestellt
aber ich funktioniert dieses ding mama
du bist sehr wichtig aber man dürfe
nichts sagen weil der füße und spaß
hätte nicht dass es so anstellen ist ein
ding aus dem putzen und überlegt man
dies einfach genauso groß wie ich für
das hier ist jetzt die aufgepumpte
luftmatratze und ihr wird schon freunde
jetzt schon relativ groß ist schon heiß
mit diesen dingen also danke auf jeden
fall für diese luftmatratze
das glaube ich nicht so klug dass ich
die kamera wieder so nahmen wasser habe
weil das letzte was passiert ist ich
gleich mal was essen sie bitte fünf
fressender fest sagt was schauen was
hier
wir haben erdbeeren haben wir glauben
wir haben die haben ein piano diese ist
ja so viel essen drin ich habe mir jetzt
das hier gemacht also ein bisschen müsli
er wäre am bein trauben und ich verstehe
nicht wieso leute diesmal so hinlegen
dass ich jetzt auch mal aber danach
macht man doch wieso und ist es dann
also hempel du kleiner bastard das wort
durchweg ich gehe jetzt wenn man eltern
was essen ich finde es
ich würde es aber auch schlafengehen
freuen ich bin wirklich total caro von
den letzten tagen wie dem ds games
kommen
also ich würde sagen
gerade 47
ich muss mir so viele bäcker stellen
weil ich jetzt einen zahnarzttermin habe
ich hasse sarah wiener übrigens verkehrt
dass er noch von vorgestern plötzlich
viele trends gerade ist lupo vorläufig
keine abgeschaltet sind wir werden das
in den trends erst mal gesehen youtube
hat mir wieder neue verein dank youtube
dass wir uns darüber so viele bescheid
gesagt hat auf jeden fall nicht
das kann die noch einen fan wo ich mir
einen sagenhaften werden muss und werde
mich noch mit einem freund treffen aber
jetzt wollen wir erst mal zum zahnarzt
der fall jetzt zum zahnarzt
[Musik]
jetzt nicht beim zahnarzt beim zahnarzt
und wahrscheinlich bekomme ich bald alle
vier weisheitszähne erklärt und ich habe
jetzt keine richtigen schmerz oder so
dass sie deswegen raus müssten aber
derart mal dass ich so ein bisschen
verbessern sind sie fix sind ich bin auf
jeden fall war und ich hab bestücken
weil ich darf leute brauchen um kurz vor
8 uhr nicht ewig zeit hatte und ich muss
noch ein laden abholen gehen diese
ganzen schule hier bekommen jetzt
einlagen weil es hier sind die einlagen
von 30 kann so komplett mieten wieder zu
hause angekommen einlagen habe ich jetzt
auch bekommen
das ist einfach so um dass fuß links und
bis hin zu stärken
auf jeden fall freunde jetzt gedacht ich
hab hunger ich hoffe das essen aber es
macht mir das essen und hessen bei 30
mal ok hat auch meine mom gekauft auf
jeden fall habe ich jetzt einen korb
die angegebenen war leider nicht korrekt
okay da habe ich jetzt zu früher politik
und mit schüssen habe den kopf dass ich
den kopf nicht ausgepackt wahrscheinlich
sind deine eltern nicht zufrieden mit
dem ist meine damen und herren treue wer
will's angesagt der geschichte bleibt ja
ich hab einfach nicht gemerkt als ich
mich gerade mit meinem kumpel getroffen
war ich weiß nicht was ich hinten aber
ich habe überall auf dem t-shirt nass
tropfen drauf weil wir saßen draußen
doch einmal fing es an zu regnen und
irgendwie ist auch gerade hier draußen
alles sehr düster geworden ist habe ich
mich mit meinem kumpel getroffen den ich
aus der schulzeit vom gymnasium kannte
weil ihr halt überlegt hat mal eine app
zu gründenden unternehmen aufzubauen
weil da schon als wir wirklich bevor ich
youtube gemacht haben wir darüber schon
nachgedacht auf jeden fall ganz cool das
treffen und ihm auch mal wieder zu sehen
und so nur ich hatte halt kamera
vergessen egal ich denke auf dem stepper
der irgendwie wird neueste moments immer
steht das hat auch hart komme stellt
euch vor ihr kommt nach hause so nach
langer zeit nachdem also zwei monate 370
studieren war dann doch etwas steht bei
uns immer beim fitnessgeräte walter
sauerei wir machen jetzt sport geht
vielleicht ins fitnessstudio und stellt
die scheiß nicht einfach mein zimmer wie
wir das damals also wie gesagt der junge
tier der gott mir nicht dass einer von
euch morgen dem ich mir soeben einen
joghurt für das morgige frühstück in
unseren familien kühlschrank gesichert
habe darf ich euch jetzt recht herzlich
begrüßen zu einer weiteren episode von
lukas kommentiert kommentare
leute schauen wir bei meinem dienstag
vorbei heißt es dort luca da muss ich
sagen das ist richtig so heißt jeder all
meinen flossen instagram pushen will das
ist von mir übrigens nicht böse gemeint
wenn der zuschauer ein meint blogs ihren
instagram namen sagen 'ich packe
laserdrucker darüber also ist jetzt
nicht so dass ich einfach nur mehr auf
install amt will aber ich will halt
einfach nur mehr aus auf instagram ich
muss luca anrufen klingelt ja pizza ich
bin ein alpaka lokal aufgelegt okay wer
gehört auch zu lug trug ich schreibe
meine kommentare luxury werde er auch
teil von der luke rusal es läuft wenig
auch aus dem ei geschlüpft leiden coli
du bist einfach eine ukulele du bist
quasi aus einem baum geschmückt wenn ich
im nächsten video bin gebe ich dir zwei
cent so adam hier ist mein kollege hat
selbst schon 2003 stärken und bei minute
acht doppelpunkt jetzt wird es eine
bierflasche diesen kommentar habe ich so
verdammt häufig unter meinem letzten
blog gelesen jeder hat irgendwie gemerkt
dass ich immer durch eine bierflasche
rumstehen habe aber jeder der den
instagram stream gesehen hat weiß
einfach dass ich diese - flaschen von
einer zuschauerin geschenkt bekommen
habe die habe ich mir mit sicherheit
nicht selbst gekauft und ich muss
wirklich sagen ich habe mir jetzt ein
paarmal verwendete der dusche ist also
jeder weiß dass ich durch so ein
bisschen was gegen baby habe also den
content de hochlädt damit bin ich jetzt
nicht so ganz einverstanden
die sachen wie sie ihre fans teilweise
manipuliert und so weiter und so fort
habe man muss wirklich sagen wie lou
reed geil
das riecht einfach in lolli ist das
riecht einfach geil
damit würde ich jetzt allerdings auch
die heutige episode von lukas
kommentiert kommentaren aus und in dem
blog auch beenden wenn ihr euch gefallen
hat würde ich mich sehr darüber einen
daumen hoch freunde zeigt mir dass hier
auf mich hört falls ihr noch kein
abonnent von meinem kanal sein sollte
was natürlich sehr beschissen wäre wenn
dir einfach unter dem video abonnieren
klicken dann verpasst ihr keine videos
mehr und wenn ihr schon abonnent seid
könnt ihr einfach auf die glocke kleben
denn dann bekommt ihr benachrichtigungen
auf euer handy sobald ich einen neuen
blog hochladen und wenn ihnen die
nächste folge luca komplett kommentare
kommen wollte
er kommentiert irgendwas ich mit dem
block an der stelle jetzt allerdings
auch beenden und ich würde sagen wir
sehen uns dann einfach in zwei tagen bei
einem neuen blog wiederholen
[Musik]